moi je veux bien qu'on ne parle pas de
sociologie du vote mais enfin s'il ya un
vote qu'à une sociologie ses liens les
écologistes moi j'en ai une analyse
assez simple alors je reste dans mon
système de pensée un qui je sais bien qu
il est réducteur mais faut il vaut mieux
ça que l'éclectisme ont fini par
expliquer tout par toutes sortes de
facteurs différents psychologique aux
autres ce que je constate si vous voulez
c'est qu'effectivement l'électorat
l'électorat vert il est très puissant
d'ailleurs dans des élections
intermédiaires où il n'y a pas d'enjeux
de pouvoir et où l'abstention est très
forte c'est quand même caractéristique
et dans les municipales c'est très
trompeur parce qu'en fait c'est souvent
à l'issue de négociations et de têtes de
listes de gauche
l'exemple de marseille est
particulièrement révélateur mais pendant
les européennes sous l'averse beaucoup
d'ascensions devient cette bobine
abstention massive est effectivement
vous avez cette population diplôme est
relativement jeune des des villes
centres pour parler comme lui
ça ressemble beaucoup vous savez un
concept cher à mme et m marxiste c'est
un la petite bourgeoisie la petite
bourgeoise artiste et comme toute petite
bourgeoisie dont un problème ces gens là
parce qu'ils ont un statut très
intermédiaire ils ont un statut ou qui
n'ont pas mais pas de se situer
clairement dans le conflit principal
dire le conflit entre le bloc militaire
et le bloc populaire ces gens là souvent
n'aime pas du tout macron mais ils ont
pris un soin extrême à paris à ne pas se
mêler aux mouvements des gilet jaune il
déteste on peut pas me parler de
prolophobie parfois vous voyez il
déteste ces gens là ils les trouvent
réactionnaire enfin bref ça n'a pas du
tout en effet pas développer ça ça a été
fait sans foi mais en tout cas ils ont
ils ont voté par leurs pieds ces îles et
par le fait que pendant que ça se
passait en bas de chez eux contre le
pouvoir de macron il n'était pas là mais
alors pas là du tout j'ai pu le vérifier
et donc ces gens là ils ont du mal à se
situer dans le conflit principal dans le
conflit de classe principale me
semble-t-il et qui est du coup ils vont
sur des thèmes qui leur permet d'y
échapper et puis à la présidentielle bon
voilà on verra bien déjà ils sont leurs
scores et limité parce que là tout le
monde va voter ou presque est en tout
cas 80% des français et puis les enjeux
matériels prennent le dessus
une des raisons de l'impuissance des
écologistes c'est justement leur
caractéristique d'être dans un
entre-deux social qui les empêche de se
situer quand les choses deviennent
sérieuses
[Musique]